[Música]
eu me considero uma tecelã de caminhos
que ainda estão por ser escritos mas que
já existem em energia em afeto mas ainda
não em um gesto porque ainda não
encontrou a palavra que gera a
consciência e que pode construir
responsabilidade e respeito
eu sei que não é uma tarefa fácil a
minha tarefa ela mora bem no centro da
complexidade
ela bebe na inteligência dos sistemas
vivos
ela bebe no lugar mais profundo de quem
precisa fazer esforço para abrir espaço
interno onde antes existiam certezas
estreitas
então eu sei que não é pra qualquer um
eu sei que gera uma demanda nova que é
esse espaço gestacional de estar com
algo que ainda não está pronto
com o tempo com espaço com confiança
sabendo que algo novo quando a gente
planta essas três qualidade acontece e
isso curiosamente há algo que o
princípio feminino marca sobre a terra e
eu como representante legítima disso sim
aquela que escolheu encarnar deste jeito
eu carrego mas eu era absolutamente
ignorante disso hoje tentando explicar
eu vou dizer não é fácil
e porque não é fácil porque eu assim
como toda mulher
navego num oceano no cosmos em uma
multiplicidade de camadas aqui na terra
que me brindam faculdades peculiaridades
e mais três dias para as quais ainda não
tem glossário
pra nome à praia legítima para incluir e
aí então quem sabe validar valorizar
como igualmente importante pra gente
começar a falar o que é equidade de
verdade e não equidade a partir da
mulher se esforçando para entrar num
campo de construção de realidade que
homens entre qo está desenhado
muito antes do que a nossa memória
alcança a partir de faculdades
competências e dons e talentos que são
naturais ao homem como linearidade
lógica racionalidade controle métricas
nós
por sorte somos seres muito perceptivos
inteligentes e adaptáveis e fomos
aprendendo que linguagem é essa que a
gente precisa pertencer a esse mundo mas
nos gera um esforço descomunal
na hora que a gente precisa chegar nas
grandes conversas que sempre são muito
bem blindadas por pessoas muito pouco
recursa dadas em intangíveis de relações
humanas não se a profunda se elimina a
conversa antes de entender que conversa
é essa que outro está na minha frente ou
que outra abissal abismal que eu não
entendo eu não domino eu não controlo
portanto faço que ele me no eliminam
variáveis para dominar há muito tempo ea
gente vem escutando história sobre isso
repetidamente
hoje eu quero falar o que isso fez
metaforicamente falando com o feminino
feminino virou um conceito foi reduzido
a uma forma que é bonitinha feminina
saltinho alto agradável
olha só translúcida quase um anjo suave
e delicada
e eu pergunto aqui para as mulheres
quanto as mulheres se sentem
suficientemente representadas nesta
definição e quantos de vocês vazão para
além disso regularmente pois bem no
modelo mental homens entre ou patriarcal
tem uma parte que é necessária que faz
parte da inteireza da vida do movimento
de desenvolvimento natural de todas as
coisas
a vida é movimento certo tudo que está
estável
já morreu preparando a permanência então
vida é instabilidade continua o que está
faltando aqui por outro eixo além
estádio tem um eixo precioso que é o
grande eixo gerador gestha dor criador
manifestá dor do que do novo na vida uma
ligação entre o mistério o céu ea
realidade a terra quem é que tem essa
natureza que é intensa desacomodar
doadora perturbadora da ordem anterior
ou será que alguém perguntou para
semente esta jornada na semente a
senhora se incomoda da senhora deixar de
ser
de repente explodiu brotar se
desentendesse brotar uma coisinha
totalmente vulnerável que qualquer um
pega mas ainda assim você segue e vai
vai vai nutrir sustenta sustenta
sustenta pois muito bem quantos de vocês
mulheres se reconhecem
nessas competências nessas faculdades o
quanto essas faculdades estão
reconhecidas e validadas e incluídas nas
suas relações sem que você seja chamada
de ram sitam pouco excessiva é bem
escutas e se passou se acha amiga meu
não uma pessoal e aquela clássica quer
você quer ter razão é ser feliz
eu nunca serei feliz se a minha verdade
não tiver condição de ter um espaço de
existência consideração para que algo a
partir daí ela possa surgir
[Aplausos]
eu estou aqui em meu nome e em nome das
minhas filhas nome das minhas ancestrais
por todas as mulheres e por toda a
humanidade porque eu sei que as frentes
que nós abrirmos de glossário humano
relacional afetivo energético de
sustentação inteligente da complexidade
é benefício pra todo mundo essa teia não
se sustenta sozinha mas essa teia
precisa de software humano e esse
software é quem distribui é a mulher e
esse software tem que está validado como
uma competência em trem seca como uma
maestria e olha só para aí primeiro nós
podemos aprender ou não quantas você se
acha já mestras em afectos
principalmente os afectos difíceis e aí
né
falando disso eu queria fazer um pequeno
conto sobre la a viajar que os
argentinos é toda vez que começava a
fugir eu me sentia uma ameaça para mim
mesma eu sentia que tinha uma linha uma
linha tênue que eu tinha que preservar
se eu quiser se sustentar o meu espaço
de segurança é terrível é quase uma
morte cada vez que eu vou na direção da
minha verdade potente então deixou o
contador de histórias são sobre dois
mestres espirituais um homem e uma
mulher
ele repetidamente falava à mulher
a missão da mulher no planeta nesse
tempo é civilizar o homem mas é uma pena
na ela se perde na raiva e assim eu
sempre sabe quando aquele negócio em si
nossa mas por que essa condenação
desqualificação e aquilo não assentava
em mim porque algo dizem raiva é caminho
para a construção de consciência e já
volto nisso
corta nesta mulher um dia além dos
livros dela
peguei um abrir a página e pá ea ela diz
assim raiva e ela tem todos os estudos
das modulações energéticas nos corpos
das pessoas
o estudo profundo obviamente sobre o
feminino ela inclusive sendo mulher mas
estará uma um comentário genérico sobre
a raiva
então ela dizia sem raiva é energia
vital que foi represado sensacional não
faz sentido
todos os sapos engolidos eles vão
precisar ir para algum lugar certo
sapo que se engole não se dissolve então
voltando a construção de consciência que
a raiva oferece o que eu queria trazer
pra vocês é essa oportunidade de olhar
para o que não dá mais para engolir que
esta energia vermelha maravilhosa que
nos aponta para um foco nos traz
ela nos ajuda a fazer a pergunta o que
está insustentável
pra que a vida siga fluindo para que a
vida siga equilibrada e siga honrando os
seus ciclos o que é que não está honrado
em mim eu como legítimo representante
desta vida sobre a terra e que eu
imagino que conta
eu deixo essa reflexão com vocês as
emoções vêm aos pares a emoção difícil
sempre vem acompanhada de amparar a dor
é uma pena que a gente queira primeiro
eliminará difícil assim a gente nunca
chega na operadora ele diz exatamente o
oposto daquele outro mestre
veja a raio segundo joão croft
ela conta a história do desejo por
justiça
a tristeza conta a história de um amor
que foi calado
o medo conta a história de um coração
que está pulsando por experimentar se
agir
que tal o feminino não é uma forma é uma
força da natureza é um fenômeno energia
pura em movimento gerando gestando
movimentando novas realidades e trazendo
o foco para novas consciências se assim
a gente quiser nomeasse assim a gente
quiser manifestar se assim a gente
quiser caminhar sobre este planeta
e não se esqueçam se nós somos esse
vortex duplo contínuo
o caos é natural para nós e dentro do
caos é que a transição se faz e precisa
de inteligência de sustentação do caos
para atravessar processos assim eu
preparei um texto onde eu falo um pouco
da da minha utopia
o patriarcado é uma fábrica de mini
homem sustentado por subir mulheres isso
precisa mudar
os grandes números estão aí eles são
parceiros de jornada e eu queria ler
isso aqui em homenagem a esta minha
utopia porque eu vivo eu confio muito
que ela é possível então diz assim
diferente
igualmente importante agora que eu
passei seis mil anos aprendendo com você
que tal agora você aprender comigo não
para desqualificar o teu modo de ser
mas para incluir o meu que vai mexer com
a sua zona de conforto e quattor
necessidade de seu outono do critério
e do discurso então entenda eu não estou
contra você mas eu não vou mais me
encolher para que você se sinta seguro
essa é a minha responsabilidade comigo é
parte da minha evolução e pode ser parte
da tua se assim você quiser eu não vou
recuar
essa é a minha jornada eu venho em nome
da vida que está os gritos em mim e por
aí eu preciso de você
preciso de todos nós
ao meu lado não a minha frente eu sou
minha própria referência e tenho muito a
ti esclarecer
enquanto eu me esclareça isso não te
tornará menos você se tornará mais
humano mais capaz mas recursa du para
encarar a incerteza sabendo que você não
está só
eu estou com você e você tá comigo
obrigada
[Aplausos]